my name is Ruth tennon I am a
postdoctoral lecturer in the thinking
matters program at Stanford University
and I did my undergraduate degree in
molecular biology at Princeton and
that's kind of where I first got to work
in a lab um I learned what it was like
to do molecular biology and genetics and
then I went straight from college to
graduate school at Stanford and I got my
PhD here in cancer biology working in a
Labb that studies how DNA is packaged up
inside of cells so it's epigenetics lab
so I think my biggest passion about
genetics is number one the potential for
influencing on the treatment of disease
and number two it's a really cool way of
getting people excited about science so
non-scientists getting them interested
in you know human genetics or animal
genetics and it's a way to kind of spark
curiosity in both kids and adults and
get them excited about funding research
and then kind of doing research
themselves so one thing that I've
noticed is a really big push to do
incorporate Hands-On activities in the
classroom so um often times the way that
I learned most of my genetics was
through lectures and it was a great way
to learn I had fantastic teachers but I
think when you can really get your hands
wet and do a molecular cloning process
or really examine some um genomic data
it helps you really internalize and
understand things and understand them at
a deeper level than if you just kind of
listened in the classroom so I think
that sort of Project based learning and
understanding from a a Hands-On
perspective is something that's coming
up a lot now the ideal thing that would
happen with genetics in in 20 years is
that we're going to have a lot more
personalization so we'll be able to for
example let's say that you're diagnosed
with cancer we can sequence the DNA from
your cancer and design a tailored
therapy based on
this